thank you Mr CH chair my name my name is
an Gerald and I'm the uh director of
host committee services and Deborah uh
Charles who is our Deputy Chief of Staff
have planned to be here as well but
unfortunately she's stuck somewhere
waiting for a plane somewhere so she
could not make it um but I did uh we we
she and I have been in touch all morning
make sure that we had um I I would have
information that was up to the date for
you uh the first item um under the up
update on assignments by staff is that
we're still working on the master list
and we hope to have um more progress
more um give you an update on our
progress at our next meeting because it
is a lot of work as we're trying to pull
this entire them uh together and we are
having staff meetings uh weekly in the
background on this um project so on
October 16th we hope to have more
information for you um under the
continuing education program we
recognized that Thursday October 12th
was not going to be possible because we
had so many chairs who mentioned that
they really need that date uh for
retained bills
so um we thought of um December 14th um
the speaker thought this would be a good
plan as that's when we will have the
continuing education on um study
committees and
commissions um so it's not that far away
um and it will be a very vital program
we did just so people know we gave you a
handout our last meeting um I'll make
sure you get one rep vable that was
encompassing um what we thought would be
a good proposal for that program and
it's based on other programs we've done
in the past
and then the most recent item that we've
given you a sample is our trifold um
this is combination of
OLS and um our office and the graphics
and the layout and the design is by uh
Deborah Childs with Jennifer tramp's
assistance um this will be printed so
you work correct represent Dolan this
uses a lot of ink and color and it's
going to be in a brighter shade of of
blue um but we've brought this to this
meeting so that you can take a look at
it and when we meet on the 16th if you
could please review this and you have
any
suggestions um for the next meeting that
would be great but as you can see it's
to help any member who wants to
um wants to propose a study a chaptered
study or commission and it says what
would it lists out what the purpose
should be so the member when you open it
up the first panel has what the members
should
consider the purpose would be if they
want to create one then in the middle
panel it has where to begin to clarify
the need to do your research see if
something exists as we've mentioned so
many times with you before um see if
similar Studies have been n in the past
and that they can get that done in
legislative Services Research and
possibly get a legislative history on it
all discussed with uh prior study
committee or commission chair chairs
review the policy um with the policy
committee chair I mean review the study
with the policy committee chair and then
think about the best method of study so
we list some methods of study there to
think about do you want to do your own
research and not have a commission at
all um again check in with the policy
committee see see what are your options
are and they're all listed out there
with the methods of study where those
green circles are with the White
Checks then once that so so the Panet B
basically is just a guideline on how to
develop the process on how you would
think about creating a study so then um
best method is listed um will'll depend
on the subject prior studies and it
walks the sponsor through what all the
possibilities may
be um model legislation to to look at
RSA 1449 which is is what drives
everything behind the scenes in study
commissions and chaptered
studies then um as you flip this um back
panel you can see that has chaptered
studies what are they um and what's the
difference between a chapter study and a
statutory then as you fold that back
over it it walks um the member through
the process and and how you um how
things are created so this is just we
want to make it as simple and easily
identifiable as possible but
we want the committee to uh look at this
and come up with any suggestions again
this is all a draft and we can redesign
it or um make incorporate changes that
you think are important because
obviously you're the members who request
this study so um and I I don't know if I
already said this this when we printed
this out it was a darker Navy and um we
wanted more of a royal blue so our
printer upstairs prints differently than
the speaker's
printer
well we we we would have them available
everywhere so that could be a
possibility but also we'd like them um
in when we do the training we'll have it
already for the continuing ed training
we'll have them available for our own
any orientation we just want them
accessible and available everywhere so
people could see that but certainly if
OS uh wanted to or could they would have
them well Dave is right here and he's
been an intrical part of working on this
and he um they created the initial draft
and then we um did more work on it they
did a hell of a lot more work on it Dave
alonis director of legislative services
and by the time they come we start
drafting it's too late 90% of our
traffic is by email not foot traffic so
we could have piles there waiting and no
one's going to see them I think they
should be out there throughout the
course of a year would we'll have them
on our front desk but I think they
should be pretty much everywhere and
anywhere uh through the course of the
year and we're going to one of the plans
is to do an initial email and have
attached as an email um and that will be
coming from the speaker's office and um
what we did find out as we were putting
all this together is more than what's
the percentage stve like more than 50%
of our study commissions are created
through um amendments partway through
the session so certainly we we'd have
these in committees where members could
access it's ready cop in theils sure yes
every we're do it everywhere you come up
with the idea and we'll add to the list
we have a variety of places where we
want to distribute
these thank you Mr chairman thank you
very much and thank you for this it's
very helpful I think also that every
committee should have it with every
chairman reminding members who come to
testify or even their own members to
look at this and understand it and if
they have questions to bring them up
thank
you thank you for doing this it looks
great um so just where it says um use
the LSR study template is that being
developed
or so something I've been interested in
so what we're doing is a um I'm sorry I
I I don't want to do Progressive so I
can't doing this but I said losing
battle um so we are working on something
that we can come up with that might be
utilized it won't necessarily be a a
template we Dave it's some variations of
different offices depending on what you
need and we're and that's one of our as
I mentioned we're having these staff
meetings so when we have our staff
meeting this week we're going to look at
that draft and see how applicable it
will be for all of this my thought is
I'm differentiating when we use word
template at OS it's part of the the
drafting system and it's it's not
something you can print off and and look
at because it's a progressive logic in
there uh but I was thinking of something
something that's more of a worksheet uh
so something that members can maybe fill
in the blanks uh and and then and then
bring to us uh as the case may be so
that I'm calling it a worksheet and we
can work on we should rename it template
is not the right word that's just the
word we grab worksheet would make more
sense and because as you know XM
legislator which is our system that we
use in all of our offices to have the um
bills go through the process from
drafting to they end up at the Secretary
of States um this all incorporating that
we just can't print off that system um
but this would be a worksheet that that
would help a member or see the design of
what we need and we we've developed it
we've had five different versions
completely different from the others so
this most recent one hopefully will help
guide us and then we'll have that for
your review for committee members as a
homework assignment please review this
yes please and send me comments to my uh
legislative email and I'll consolidate
them and provide them to to Ann and
David and and Deborah Deborah is really
she's she's this this is Deborah she's
done a fantastic job on all this for us
she's brought it all together she so if
you have comments and suggestions for
edits or changes or whatever please get
them into me uh we will be meeting again
on the
14th we've uh successfully
negotiated our our our meeting day so
that we uh are trying to make sure we
don't step on any of
the I think it's actually the 16th that
we're meeting sorry the 16 the 16th so
that we we don't step on any of the
religious holidays that are upcoming uh
so so hopefully that that fits
everybody's schedule so please get them
into me as soon as you can and
um sorry yeah date for the next meeting
Monday the 16th at 1
o' and then the um last item that we had
for uh handouts um was uh Brad greenin
in our office went through the LSR list
and he found it's it's um it's a chart
that you have
uh it's this chart right and in it um
lists the 30 lsrs that are in the titles
uh as of now as of now 15 chapter and 15
statuto so you can see the titles of
the um statuto which are commissions
those are all italicized so you can
break them out easily to read them and
then the um commissions are chaptered
studies are in regular uh print and it
just lists you can see the titles um and
you can see the drafters excuse me
sponsors so you may be able to um
inquire uh the reasoning behind wanting
to submit those and then um we have the
ls Brad also included lsrs repealing a
Comm commission we have
um told committees repealed one and
total commissions repealed three so
there's four of those and then we have
lsrs amending a committee or commission
and that's um total commissions to be
amended seven of
them so that's to date that was um as of
Friday and then this is only house this
has not include Senate
yet yeah I was mentioning to
representative AEL that almost feels
like from a committee standpoint we're
shoveling sand against the ti as we T it
feels like as we tackle these with more
coming up it's like talking to the
wall it
it so we thought that that would be a
helpful list for the committee to see
well it certainly does point out the the
the problem that uh that we've got and
we're working
on and not making a lot of progress
yet go ahead I'm sorry excuse me I'm
sorry and and so those were my only
items unless anybody had um any
questions we will have more updates for
you on the 16th because as I mentioned
we are working staff is working um as we
can bring everybody together um and and
because we we prefer toing as much as a
final product to you so you're not
wasting your time looking at all of our
drafts in the background but we like to
update you with the work that we are
doing and um it was my understanding
that the speaker was going to be here
but I think he may have a conflict I'm
not yeah I'm not he's a busy guy um POS
I did
um okay so yes he what he's not um I
don't believe he's gonna be able to make
it so um that is
um that is where we are to date anybody
on the committee have comments or
questions for for our pres presenters
today yes I'm not here able to be here
on the 16th and I know that we left this
topic but it seems like we're just kind
of wrapping everything up here and I
just wanted to ask on the LSR uh
worksheet which I think is a really good
idea you will you be Pro
well you'll be thinking about how you'll
be disseminating it I was just thinking
if you send this out online it would be
really neat to just have a hyperlink to
the worksheet that somebody could click
on and then my only other thought was
that the worksheet if it could include
the important parts of
1449 like sort of giving them they need
to have a fiveyear repeal date and you
know
we and maybe you have that in mind but I
just wanted to make that comment since I
won't thank you repr yes we do have that
because we have a more this is just a
quick overview and we do have a a sheet
that goes into more detail exactly what
you've mentioned the reminders of these
are the other items that are
included I think it's and one of the
items as well is that to consider when
you're requesting a study commission to
to know how long it will take to
possibly get all the appointments made
and that it may be eating up your time
as you're trying to um get to the um
point of
study now we were here on the trifold
what I let's say that
um I'm in a I'm on a
committee um and standing committee and
I want to re search and or have the
committee look at an issue and I'm
getting ready to propose new legislation
that would study some
issue what where in in the trifold would
I get the suggestion or guidance that
but
first ask the committee chair to see if
they can take it up as as a study within
the committee like you know like a three
a three representative person study
as opposed to appointing a a so um Mr
chair that's where we have where we have
under where to begin and we have review
with policy chair that is um item number
four right that would be where that is
because we're also going to be working
with the chairs to make them aware of
all this um and so that's why we
suggested that there and again because
this has this was an abbreviated version
and the one that will go into more
detail as you suggested representative
evil that will have the specific
explanation in there that can can this
be solved by a um subcommittee of a
policy committee could a standing
committee can this issue be reviewed in
that manner so uh question for you David
let's say that uh someone comes forth
with an LSR that wants to like one of
these here U establishing a
committee uh
and let's say that the chair Su
intercedes uh and talks to the member
and says let's do this instead instead
of creating a committee let's study it
within the
committee um if that intervention is
successful well I guess I'm I'm
proposing how it work would work if that
intervention is successful how how do we
what's the mechanics of pulling back the
LSR and and any sponsor can ask for the
bill to the LSR to be withdrawn up until
introduction so assuming that's going to
be the first week in January that's the
that would be the date so when it gets
numbered and put out there that that
then it becomes property of the house
and not of the sponsor okay so so let's
say that that the sponsor agrees to
withdraw in lie of this other activity
are all the co-sponsors also notified or
how how do we what's the the process
being completed in order to do
that co-sponsors can take on a bill if
if the sponsor uh chooses not to but I
have not seen that to be the case if the
sponsor wants to withdraw that it simply
gets withdrawn okay okay anyone have any
comments about that process and that can
happen after this this Prime sponsor
signs off or after be done for the
January deadline yes when by the way
when in January is that is that the
first week in January
um I'm not I'm not sure about that that
date but it's right in early
January could you help us find out what
that date is I think it's the first
Wednesday first day of
okay anyone else have any questions for
our distinguished guest speakers yes one
more yeah um I know that we've s we've
been really encouraging people to check
with OS and do research in advance of a
decision I'm I I was curious whether
you'd seen an uptick in um research
inquiries and
absolutely you had absolutely uh those
four folks have been slammed uh this
fall unfortunately a lot of it was in
the last day or two of of uh LSR
submission so some pretty large requests
for research came in with one day left
before you could file so there's not
enough lot how many how many lsrs have
there been there's roughly 800 uh house
lsrs and uh a number of them have been
uh
withdrawn as duplicates because in some
cases we're only now realizing what is a
duplicate things could come in from two
different members end up with two
different working titles but then you
come to find out they're pretty much
exactly the same when you start opening
up the do do we do anything with u
screening for duplicates that come from
the Senate as
well the Senate has no rules to that so
they uh they can they can bring anything
forward as many times as they want
do they come through your office yes
yeah same process all Senate lsrs are
and their filing period is ongoing right
now and uh they come in usually it's
their AIDs that bring in the uh the
request uh and and we put it forward the
only difference between the house system
and Senate system is that the the Senate
allows for confidential lsrs so when you
when you see the list and the first list
that will have some that'll have Senate
lsrs will be put on the public site
later today hopefully uh and that'll be
a list of somewhere between 40 and 50
there's I think a couple of uh house
lsrs that were kind of sitting around
that will be included but uh if you look
at the numbering there's always going to
be gaps in the numbering now once we get
to the Senate and those are lsrs that
are confidential requ requested by the
senator and in that case they do not
introduction okay thank you yes well I
was just going to follow up and just say
I'm glad to hear that they're you know
be careful what you ask for right but um
I mean I like to think that the use of
the research folks affected the number
and the quality of the lsrs that were
submitted so we'll see I mean 30 is a
lot but I've seen many more study
committee bills filed I mean I don't
know how many there are on average
but hopefully we dampen TI yeah I think
I think the yes Matt go ahead well I
just gonna say I I think there's that
opportunity you know for the speaker and
you you know with chairs to
encourage uh you know the establishment
of some subcommittees you know so that
we don't actually need to see some of
these study committee and study
commission uh bills become lot that
there there is an Avenue to do this
outside of legislation so even though
it's at 30 right now it could be some of
them are probably not you know wouldn't
pass anyways but um you know if there's
a bipartisan interest in pursuing a
specific topic um you know it could be
easy enough to to pursue it uh you know
through the committee process yeah the
let me say that the the research folks
are a big help I I can speak from
personal experience this this session uh
that I was getting ready to put in uh an
LSR on an issue around boting
the details aren't important but u i I
had found through some minimal research
that I had done and some encouragement
from the research folks that that the
issue had already been tackled in in a
bill that was put forth by the Senate a
couple of years ago and I really needed
to research what was done slash not done
with that bill before I put in another
dup so-called duplicate Bill along very
similar lines so I I withdrew my my
effort uh to do that research probably
and maybe will file next year but uh
their their help is invaluable in fact U
I have found them uh being being able to
research across the entire country as to
what other legislators are doing in
other states along similar subject lines
it's been very helpful and they and they
do that every every day and it's there's
always something different going through
that office every day because there's a
lot of different topics that they that
they look into we were just talking
about uh one of the the 50 state surveys
that that my and crew were doing this
morning regarding one piece of
legislation great so please uh take back
our appreciation for their hard work
it's greatly appreciated thank
you anyone else have have comments about
any Topic at all that we're pursuing or
not
pursuing
okay thank thank you very much
appreciate
it okay so so where are we now so so
we're looking at uh 10:16 as our next
meeting and we're going to have have
everybody hopefully uh take a cut at
this trifold not just the colors but the
the content and uh and get those
comments to me and for some reason if I
drop dead get them right to an directly
um
you never know you never
know you never know uh and uh we'll
we'll review that those comments on the
14th and uh if we need to we'll we'll
tag the the vice chair to step up in
case of my
us and uh and we're not going to forget
we get already some comments about
having a hyperlink and also the
1449 uh limitations so we've got that
already as
feedback uh so that's
important um so I just want to let you
know that
that my
intent uh and I I don't have any push
back from you all on this yet but my
intent was to uh tap the individual
house chair on the on the shoulder and
invite them to these to one of these
meetings upcoming meetings along with
their Vice chair and their uh ranking
member to M suggestion uh so that we we
make sure that that we're fair about
this and ask them to come to this
meeting and talk about uh what is on
their table as far as uh uh committees
and commissions that they have cogn over
or should have cognizance over and then
what will be their suggestion to reduce
the their uh utilizing the various
strategies in our in our trifold or in
just in discussion what would be the
various strategies to reduce that number
uh could be
consolidating uh taking taking it up
within their their committee as opposed
to putting it out as a as new
legislation Etc uh and ultimately if if
we have a couple dozen committees in the
house and if we can get I'm I'm just
shooting in the dark here if we can get
them to all
agree kill one of their committees
that's 24 committees that we can we can
uh tackle and hopefully it's more than
one maybe it's two or three uh but you
know if we can get so I've already
spoken with with the technology uh
committee uh that the uh I spoke with
the the vice chair he's going to round
up uh his folks and I've uh at least
made an attempt to talk to Health and
Human Services uh Wayne McDonald is the
chair and so you know I'm gonna try to
pick them off you know one or two at a
time and get them invited to get them on
our agenda get them sitting here and
open up a discussion about about the
strategy to
reduce
uh their activity in this Arena and
maybe some specific suggestions to them
and from them uh for uh for
reduction uh that's on their plate in
front of
them hopefully that will be successful
we'll see make a few a few attempts at
at it and staff is welcome to to come
we'll let you know ahead of time who
we're going to be interviewing and and
and suggestion I I'm under the belief
that that we're going to talk to chairs
and vice chairs and I I really think
that in many cases they're not even
going to know what's on their
plate uh and they're going to say you
know we're going to say from our
Viewpoint you
have 20 committees that you should be uh
overseeing and they're and they're going
to have puzzled looks on their face and
I'm only aware of two or three and we're
going to have to help educate them and
they're going to have to help uh get
back to us to say okay now I recognize
what I've got and here's what my
strategy is going to be or here I'm
going to go off and think about it and
work with uh with my committee my uh in
the leadership of my committee both
both uh both sides of the aisle this
this this should not be a we're going to
do this even though you don't want to do
it I think I think we ought to be
looking for those opportunities that we
all can agree on are good opportunities
not we're not I don't think we're need
to especially at this early point in the
process I don't think we need to force
anything down anybody's throat I think
there's enough opportunities out there
that we can uh we
can agree be agreeable
and and moving on on many of these
things any any thoughts on that yeah
John I I have a question basic it's for
an my my question in on the master list
completion because you know when when we
have all these chairs come before us we
better have a master list of what
they're responsible for because you know
they probably don't it's probably going
to be a while because we're working with
the it to finalize it all but if you
recall that list that we gave you two
weeks ago before that of the 12 items it
worked off of Representative eil list
from when we had that last um extensive
very extensive two-year overview and
that report is in your binder so as I
asked representative Dolan earlier was
that the plan to to start another study
in that manner but a different vehicle
and that you go the chairs first so this
would be a different um development so
what we so what this master list is
right now would basically as I know the
bill number the bill and and a whole
bunch of different
categories and um it will be broken down
by we can we're we're working with it
see how we can manipulate it to be
once's just for health but as we've told
you before there may be one that you
will think is Health but actually may be
overseen by Science and Tech because of
some of the nature it might be overseen
by children of family and so that's
where it's going to take a while to
figure out where those little ones are
um and we're and that is part of this
overall um program this program is being
designed for the entire legislature to
be able to uh look at so so it will be
available to all staff because every
office has something a little bit
different that they're looking for in
this system so we'd be better able to
answer that question of what what the
time frame is probably at the 16th when
we're going to um talk about that and we
so John just so so you know my my
thought is baby
steps uh so if I if I if we identify
like we talk about science and
technology and HHS for example if we go
to legislative services and say I want
to start with those two
committees that perhaps legislative
Services rather than looking at all the
Committees and what all the uh the
different commissions and committees
that flow into them if we just take one
or two at a time then maybe legislative
Services can help us peek into the files
and say okay on HHS there they have
these 20 committees to look at rather
than what are the 400 committees that
that tear into the you know I don't want
to overload you guys or ask you for
something that you're not ready to I
what I do know about from when this
process was done before um
representative eil it was two-year
process correct and it takes a lot and
so we did have um at that point one
staff person devoted to it so and we
have done this uh four or five times in
the last 15 years so I think that's what
maybe we'd go back and reexamine how we
did all that that and we can come up
with better idea on how to start the
search I mean we can talk about this
some more but I would say when we did it
the approach that we took was that we we
identified the agencies who were
responsible and worked with the various
commissions so that they could come in
and talk about the activities of the
commission sometimes the chairs of those
commissions would come in
um I think it's really a good idea to um
to educate existing chairs of committees
on the commissions that relate to their
subject matter but I honestly don't
think that the chairs of those standing
committees are going to know very much
about all of these committees how much
they meet what their subject matter is
and if we expect them to just identify
by a couple um I
mean in some cases they may be stabbing
in the dark I mean we did a really
comprehensive long-term process and it
was only two years ago so I mean I guess
the master list you'll show how many are
still active and how many are still
doing
reports um I mean the
other I guess the other question here is
when we when we did our work we didn't
presume to have the substantive
knowledge of any of these commissions
and committees when they came in and
they said look we're doing good work
we're producing reports the way we're
supposed to be we looked at it
objectively and we said yeah you you
guys really are doing the work that
you're supposed to do and a lot of them
do I mean just because they're a
commission it doesn't mean they're not
doing useful work um so I just I just
say all of that because I think it's
it's it's going to be challenging for uh
standing committee chairs to really have
the full amount of knowledge that they
would need to have to even have a
opinion on this no I agree I like I said
I think we're going to have committee
chairs come back to us with a big shrug
on the shrug on the shoulders and say
they don't know but I but I think that's
one of the obstacles we need to
overcome as far as information to them
is make sure that they
understand what their umbrella covers so
that they can start having more
influence on on what happens with those
committees that that that because
because I know that in in some
cases committees and commissions are are
sometimes
established because there are promises
made to constituents about uh
looking into a subject matter or
whatever and and no and not very many
people have a have a an interest in it
and it just gets it just gets uh listed
and it nothing not a lot happens to it
uh you don't get quorums people don't
languishes yes uh Mr chair what well one
of the things you've just mentioned that
was part again part of the the
initiatives of all these previous
substantial um studies in the in the um
as as represent yel mentioned they
brought in those people testify and
there a good number of commissions that
exist we may only have one or two
legislators on there but they do that
they're involved with requirements they
need to exist because the Department of
Education needs it to meet a federal
requirement and that was all found out
two years ago and then four years before
that and then six years before that then
eight or whatever the breakdown is so
that's why in your binders if you look
in your binders all those reports are in
there and the initiatives are all listed
so we gave you the full reports but we
can go in there and pull that out or we
can possibly redesign some of this
information because I again um as we've
mentioned when you have the policy
chairs to come in and discuss that they
may not necessarily know uh a
legislative a create a
commission that was created by the
legislature for HHS for some reason that
where it it's it exists for the agency
not necessarily for us but this would be
another exercise in trying to find all
that out I don't know how much of the
information has been how much has
changed in 24 months so I think that's
how you you might want to think think
about that um do you do you build upon
the information we've already collected
even though it's only a couple years old
or do you want to um look at it from a
different angle right I understand I
think the where I'm go going with this
is is
ownership I'm afraid that that many of
these committees or commissions have
lack of ownership within the legislature
and they they just kind of on their own
or the bureaucracy of the of the state
is is driving the the continuation of
the activity and I I think if we look at
the cost of government and what we're
trying to
accomplish for for the people in the
state I think that there are some some
flaws in in the in the way that we
approach this I know this is a
philosophical point but I'd like to see
a
a I think we should look to have a
greater state of ownership from the
committee chairs as to as to what these
various committees and commissions are
up to and whether or not we want them to
continue uh We've we've had a lot of
activity since since the coid crisis
where in many cases uh these commissions
and committies have been overcome by
events and haven't met in years and I
think that we those deserve a hard look
say are they really if they haven't met
in years are they really not necessary
maybe they
are I can think of one where
uh in the uh Edna world the issue of of
statistics of of of race and ethnic
backgrounds and so forth uh was was
looking to have its its own committee uh
to oversee you know that status and what
we found was
what the the chair of the that committee
found was that UNH was providing that
free of charge uh to the to us to the
legislature and the need for the a
committee to go gather that same data
was superflous and we should just accept
what UNH was was doing review it and the
committee could could control it from
that from there we need need a a
separate committee or a separate
commission to run that so so then that
should just one example but there may be
several other examples like that out
there where what we what we want the
good the good work that that needs to be
done that we want is available to us and
or available to the legislature and
there may be a better or and less
information well we are stop we're here
to do whatever you want us to do so um
moving forward obviously we'll have the
information for you on the 16th and um
and then we could go from there uh just
whatever you'd like us to do no you're
doing a great job we appreciate thank
you had hadn't you identified several
commissions that hadn't met or had you
gone through again we gave you the
list last week I'm sorry because I
thought you've done some work on updated
there's 12 of them I believe right now
12:15 and you all got a chart last week
and the last column gave list of where
they had met so we have done that we did
go through see it was built again upon
what you had done your commission and so
we um gave that to but as far as we know
the others have Mee like we found one
that's been meeting regularly but they
not all these commissions know that they
need to get us the information to so
that it's entered into our database they
they start meeting on their own and
again because they're involved within an
agency they believe they only need to
let the agency know and and after so
many years while they're working really
hard they just have no idea that if it
doesn't they don't book their meetings
here with our house Clerk or Senate
clerk it's not going to get into the
database that we maintain so some of
that we we have found but um yes that
most recent list
um that's up to date as far as we could
find a
step and one of those you kind of
Representative of kof's uh suggestion we
identified one of them as a
as a Target if you will
to to decommission going forward I can't
remember we we're going to ask one of
the Committees to uh committee chairs
to on I believe representative hunt had
a bill that was U repealing education
was it Commerce Commerce and so there I
believe that the suggestion was that if
there are other committees or
commissions to be appeal that that would
be a a vehicle that we could
potentially would use it and would amend
that and add other committees to that
right
potentially um Mr chair I just want to
mention there was also one and oh the
speaker right here so he
came thank you Mr Speaker I appreciate
usting
yours so this is where we are right
L can I just have a minute to see where
gone uh
um oh sorry I wasn't here earlier but
um I guess there's a couple of things
that have been brought to my attention
and
um I know there's a question about
whether putting a new bill in or using
the retain bill that we already
have uh I would strongly suggest we use
have uh the other thing is I know that
and and Deborah and a few others put a
list of uh committees
that I think there's 15 16 that they
suggested that might be
repealed uh I would strongly also
suggest that you bring in the the
whoever is the contacting that and and
ask them if they are doing anything or
they have done anything or they're going
to do anything before you just put them
on the
list and uh the third thing is uh I
understand Mr chairman you were looking
at getting all the chairs in and talking
to them I'm not sure that would be
beneficial to you a lot of the chairs we
have are
new and frankly I doubt if they have a
knowledge of a lot of the commissions
that are out there at this time that may
be something you might want to look at
down the road but I think you know at
this point in time I mean maybe John
Hutt knows everything in his committee
but uh realistically a lot of the other
new chairman I don't think really know
uh what commissions are underneath them
and what they've actually done and I'm
not sure if that would be you know a
useful you use of time at this at this
point I agree I I think what we're
looking for is a to create a sense of
ownership so that the chairs would
own the issues with their with their u
under their umbrella if you will make
sure they understand that oh by the way
you have 20 committees that fan out
underneath you and so if we Define that
help help them Define that then that
might kind of clear the weather a little
bit and see which ones should they go
after either consolidate or get rid of
and that might be a useful tool a little
bit down the road but I think at this
point if we concentrate on what the list
you have and I don't even what that list
is at this point and uh and see if we
can't get that done because I can tell
you and I I I think uh representative
Wilhelm you've already gone through the
list as I have a couple of times we've
got about another 30 that have already
been filed this year yeah we had that
list so uh you know I I've gone through
it twice and yeah
I well yeah I I'm not sure I want to see
it uh but we we do have another 30 or so
so if we get rid of 15 we're still we're
still behind uh you know but I I would
strongly uh ask that you you know that's
the next step you might want to go
with good suggestion thank you Mr
Speaker I I'll try and answer any
questions but I know the staff has done
a tremendous job putting this stuff
together for your uh I honestly got to
say it wasn't
me no an and her staff and along with
Deb Childs have done an outstanding job
helping us you know focus on what what
we can uh what we can work on what's
available to us and also steer us away
from those things that that aren't going
to be helpful
and create help create some timelines
about we uh you you have in front of you
the tri I do and I will uh I will
uh look at it I haven't seen it myself
but I
will let me ask you this put you on the
spot a little bit do you have any
specific goals you'd like to see us
achieve uh in terms of reducing the
commissions if it was up to me I'd
probably get rid of just about every
single one of them but that's not
reality and that's not what's going to
happen so I think realistically we have
to go after the ones that either aren't
meeting haven't met or uh you know have
really no intention of meeting and then
at some point I still think there's a
lot of them out there especially in
Health and Human Services uh you know
there's so many of them out there I
can't believe that we can't start
combining some of those well I speaking
of that particular committee I've spoken
with Wayne McDonald about bringing uh
himself his vice chair and the uh
ranking member of his Committee in to
discuss that that issue specifically I
know he's a new chair to that committee
so U well maybe he can help educate us
and we educate him along with an's help
as to what's in front of him that that
the other one is education they've got a
tremendous amount education and and
health and ement
services I've lost track of
them I just so Mr speaker thank you for
coming um so would your thought be for
the 12 or whatever that um staff has
identified the commissions that haven't
been meeting that we could maybe use a
process like we had used before and have
an agency
representative that is responsible plus
the chair of the committee to come and
talk about that committee's activities
and then the the our committee could
make a recommendation based on that
input whether to because we could have I
mean when we did it before we we would
meet for a couple hours and we could
have you know several of the people come
in in one meeting and then you could
talk about it at the end of the meeting
and kind of decide objectively how you
thought it would proceed so after I mean
if we're able to do that in a not you
know in the next know six weeks or
whatever your idea would be that we try
to amend a retained Bill maybe through
pledge admin as opposed to a going to
rules with a late filed bill or or I
think it might be hard but I think it
would be a lot easier using that
retained Bill than it would be to file a
new bill yeah and I that's exactly what
I was going for is just bringing in
somebody from the agency or the the
chairman or yeah whatever we did it
before it worked really well right and
and find
out why if when why and all that stuff
you know and uh maybe even though it's
been identified maybe they plan on doing
something or maybe there's a you know a
real good reason why they haven't done
something well and sometimes they
actually recommend repeal they'll come
in and say you know what really we don't
need this anymore and you'd maybe be
doing us a favor by repealing it so you
don't really know right until until you
have them come in and based on the work
um an has you probably know which agency
and and and how to reach out for the
ones that aren't
meeting I mean I've told you before we
had a situation where it was like a a
County finance committee that hadn't met
really since the dawn of time and Health
and Human Services came in and said this
is a commission that exists for very spe
very specific specific circumstances but
if they don't exist we can't proceed one
way or another so you know they were
really so that particular one we didn't
recommend repealing but they may have a
different view on it now um but they do
sometimes they're like yeah take it away
we haven't met in five years and you can
take it away you know I'll be happy I
mean you just you can't predict that and
they're really the ones that know the
most about what's happening and not the
standing committee
chairs right that that's that was my
point yeah one of the things that we are
I think uh we can declare hopefully an
early success is the trifold that we're
uh it's under development right now
close to finishing is something that
David's going to take to OS and provide
input to legislators who are getting
ready to propose an LSR for new
committees or new commissions and make
making sure that they understand there
is a process to follow now legis
legislators can still choose not to
follow the process but at least
hopefully this will give them some
guidance uh and and we we're GNA I think
is it is in December have an education
session with
them um with new legislators as to not
new but legislators before the next
session that this is the the process
that we expect that they're going to
follow
most of the
time so in advance we want to thank
David
for doing that and and Ann and and
Deborah for
creating and and the supporting staff it
is a lot of work we do appreciate it Mr
chair I just I'm I'm trying to figure
out the timing here if we want to amend
a retained bill and the retained bills
are supposed to be reported out by the
Committees by November 17
were sort of on
a tight or what what would you think
what I suggest is uh depending on how
many of those bills that how many of
those uh commissions you've been given
um you know your next uh session you
concentrate on that so um I I would
think you could probably get an answer
in 15 minutes or so per commission I
don't think you need a much longer than
that to find out what they've done or if
they doing anything or they plan to and
that way there within
maybe you know maybe one good solid day
you could find out all the information
on them and then you could keep on
moving on on the other stuff you want to
do and that way they would allow the
plenty of time to get it over to uh you
know that retained bill over and and and
amend it yeah and you have a suggestion
how to get that information yes it's
already there if you pull out the chart
that we gave you at the last meeting the
last column list what the status is of
every one of those whether it's repr h
was going to repeal one believe somebody
else is going to repeal one one group
has been meeting regularly since Co but
they haven't been here so I believe
there may be a few that the committee
will have to investigate but it's all
there on the last column so you have it
all laid out for you as well so with an
explanation um and um and I believe
there should be a contact person there
as well do you need a copy of that P
yeah I mean not sure I have a copy if I
have forgot send to but I mean yeah
that's just the way we did it the staff
I uh identified the right person at the
agency I mean some of these bills may
all may be within one agency and that
person came in and sometimes the chairs
of the commission came in depending on
what it was and sometimes they didn't
but I mean we got a whole lot of
information from the from the agencies
we we took them a agency by agency work
really the committee wants an additional
copy of what was passed out at the last
meeting maybe an
it just you Karen yeah I'll I'll BR you
need a copy I think you do represent set
I don't okay okay so so representative
you set or is
available do your your legi admin
uh email
works yeah okay all right we can make a
hard copy before you leave today okay
and and I'm happy to just take a look at
it and talk to and so we can I mean and
make a recommendation based on our
previous experience on on the best way
to proceed for that there's one that we
selected representative cof that was the
uh the educate well no was korous one it
was the one that representative hunt was
repealing right and now we're going to
use that as a model I
guess I think that the speaker just
mentioned there is legislation in
legislative Administration it's the
Senate bill that was retained and I
believe that you were going to use as
your vehicle you you've talked about
that right before and I think um and I
do know that representative uh Greg Hill
the chairman has plans to schedule a
work session for October
11th so so the information needs to get
to um the chairman to know that you're
working on that and you going to be
that yes so so I think once we get that
as an example then we can we
can we can edit it to include any other
bills we want to add to it yes So the
plan is we won't execute on the 11th
we'll hold it
until uh we find out's the number
sb84 uh do we the rest of us or any of
us need to be there to help testify or
to reinforce or you think you've got it
okay good any other thoughts about this
representative War you look like you're
here okay our next meeting is on the
16th thank all done with me thank you Mr
speaker thank you Mr Speaker I
appreciate your
inputs um Mr chair Jen just said she is
making a copy for everyone here just
because we did add one more we found one
more so she's adding that and she's
printing that out right now for everyone
okay we won't we won't uh and we will
email it to you as well we won't leave
until we get
that representative noan do we want to
plan out another meeting after that like
for October 30th just so we everyone can
see that too we can give it kind of a
Halloween
theme you know the death of many
commissions I have a Ghostbuster one how
how does the 30th look for you
any conflicts if we meet if we schedule
another meeting for the
30th good good idea okay one o'clock on
the
30th all right
and you can come in costume right and
could you help us make sure that gets
posted oh yes absolutely that's again
Jamie's listening right now so Jamie
will thanks
Jamie good okay and and the one for the
16th has already been posted I I noticed
record we good Mr and do you know offand
if there if the bills
are like if a bunch of them are Health
and Human Services or a bunch of them
are education or they're all different
agencies they're all different represent
EV yes they are there's it's a
variety and some may not even fall under
an agency I don't know so for instance I
believe that the wet commission is one
of them and I don't know if that's would
come under public works or where that
would go so there are some that are like
that and then you're right I think
someone mentioned the demographics um
that this the chair mentioned that I
believe that might be there but as as
you we do know some one in Science and
Tech I think representative Harrington
mentioned that should be repealed
representative hunt has another one
there it was part of the leftovers that
you had from your commission we knew
they we need to continue um you need to
continue work on those so we found that
list and then um a whole bunch of
different staff looked at everything and
we we added to this list and the speaker
was hoping we could get up to 20 but we
I think we get up to
15 well this to follow the speaker's
lead um education and HHS appear to be
very fertile ground for for us to be
looking at so so we'll keep that in mind
as we start looking at these the
different areas in terms of quantities I
mean if if we've got a for example if
HHS has 50 of them outstanding then uh
we should be able to round a few of few
of them up to to put on the list Mr
chair some of it will take a while as
represent tell because some of those do
have Federal Regulations so we're going
to have to work closely with the agency
people sure to find so we'll grabb your
list from
20 2021 we'll take that and we'll just
and we'll just contact all those people
I believe Pam probably has all records
so we'll know who to call the agency to
ask them again is this still in
existence and maybe that's our starting
point and we'll go from there well appre
appreciate you being here aronas uh we
need your guidance oh you're very kind
listening
and speak of the devil here are the here
are the handouts that we just was
speaking
about Jen just mentioned that the first
one is the extra one
um but as you can see
um this this list uh it starts off with
the commer citation the year was created
what um the current appointments of the
members see the members who are
appointed the associated uh
agency and then any agency comments uh
that's listed in there and then the
final column are the notes where uh we
did some research and we found out what
um anything that will help you make your
decision
um what's the new new one that was added
271 um Association do or
Dees
right and the one that representative
kofalt recommended was
uh was uh 28
B1 um it is one it should be no it would
be on the second page um it is under
citations under RSA
404 uh DJ oh I see you and you'll see
the final under the notes it says
represent represent hunt said he will
file a bill to repeal this um we may not
need to as the sunsets with the final
2024 and it looks like representative
Harrington already filed a bill yes he
that
well all right any last comments before
we
adjourn again uh an and David thank you
for your work and Brad and and others
who are watching
online thank you you work on this we
need all all the help we can get and uh
we appreciate appi and for the members
who came
today uh thank you so much for your
attendance any last comments from
adjourn